[Music]
one of the most common questions i get
is what is gaslighting like what's
what is it why what is it i don't know
what this looks like i hear it all the
time and now people are calling each
other gas lighter guess
here gas lighting is this gaslighting is
a form of control
where someone makes you question your
reality
right they make you feel crazy as a
means of getting what they want
so a good example is
uh you're with somebody in abusive
relationship and
a few months later
um
you're explaining this to somebody right
or you explain to them hey you hurt me
all the time and they're like i don't
ever hurt you
you take things too seriously
and
you just have really thin skin so when i
shoved you i don't i didn't push you
that hard i don't know what else
happened to you but i did not bruise you
um
or oh my gosh i told you that
that you looked ridiculous and
overweight in that dress you know i was
kidding
um
you know that you're the one that tells
me that you want to lose weight right
gaslighting
it's a form of control whereby somebody
makes you feel crazy they alter your
sense of reality
as a way of getting what they want okay
so
what does that look like in real life
what's a good picture of that
um
there is no better picture i wish i had
a better one i'm sure there maybe exists
but i was watching a movie recently with
my daughter
and the movie is
tangled
right and here's let me set it up for
you
the young girl rapunzel got some notes
here is forced to stay alone in a tower
with a woman who's pretending to be her
mother
and who in reality kidnapped her when
she was a baby
she makes rapunzel sing to her to keep
her young forever and shelters her from
the world
sounds a lot like james's kids but
whatever this is two so we got two
different clips spliced together here um
so yes as a gang we're all going to go
through a couple of scenes here in in
this movie tangled it's an incredible
display of gaslighting and i just want
to walk through it a little bit
and also if you're listening to this on
podcast go to the youtube channel and
watch it okay because we've got it
spliced up to where it's great and
sarah's doing her editing magic there
but it's a great way to see it and to
experience it and if you sit on and
actually experience this
it i get enraged i get so frustrated
angry so all right so here we go nate
dog let's uh hit the hit the play button
and let's get after
by the way she's don't pull your kids
hair by the way if you're watching this
that's just
that's just
101 don't pull your kid's hair
[Music]
hi
welcome home mother ugh rapunzel how you
managed to do that every single day
without fail it looks absolutely
exhausting darling oh
it's nothing then i don't know why it
takes so long oh
darling i'm just teasing
[Laughter]
all right
so mother as you know tomorrow is a very
beautiful look in that mirror you know
what i see
i see a strong confident beautiful young
lady
oh look you're here too
i'm just teasing stop taking everything
so seriously
ah that's it okay i had to stop it
i want to stop it like four times just
now
ah
and thankfully look at that look face
ugh
she's actually doing that anyway
all right so i want to stop it like four
times already here's the thing
anytime you say somebody says something
to you followed by
just kidding
that's a good sign that's an alarm
system that somebody's gaslighting you
okay
here's a rule of thumb for life and it's
an exhausting way to live
and it's uh
it's not always great
okay i'm just i'm prefacing that right
but gasoline's so prevalent in our
culture we approach each other with
sarcasm so much we we have no way of
entering into each other's spaces with
hey how's it going so everything's got
to be a snark about the president or
about a thing or about politics or about
those people or about you and your shirt
oh the nice shoes you picked today right
and i'm as guilty as anybody i just i
just i just did this with james kids
james has some
has four of the most incredible children
ever anyone who's around james's kids
walks home and with their head down like
they failed as a parent
they just do that's just what it is he's
just a better parent than all of us and
the way i combat my shame of my kids who
the other night we uh i gave them all a
bath then we had dinner and we were
quieting the house down and then all of
a sudden i look out the window and my
two kids are sprinting into the woods
one of them has a like a wooden sword
the other one's got like a shopping cart
and a stick like what it
i think of james's kids who are like yes
papa and then they go home and they like
anyway
i do that by i don't know how to enter
james of space and be like hey by the
way you're a great dad i don't know
that sounds weird
and like we're gonna hug or something so
what i do is i just make fun of his kids
right and then i go oh just kidding and
so i want you to always be weary of the
other side of a compliment
maybe weary is too strong but just
notice it
hey you do a great job
i just wish it was a little more better
or i really like the way you uh do the
dishes i sure wish
you uh
could care about our kids as much
as sure man such a nice thing you did
for that person at church today sure
wish you loved your family that much ah
just just kidding just kidding boom
right boom
gaslighting is
almost always
um insult followed by just kidding and
as a quick aside
one of the most shameful moments and
this is me being like completely honest
one of the most shameful moments of my
professional career is when i was in a
counseling um this is when i was
in a counseling conference
and the woman who was presenting said by
the way you know the kids can't um
process sarcasm right and i was like
excuse me there's a room of us right
there's a speaker
she said yeah up until about seven eight
nine ten um kids cannot process sarcasm
they internalize it
as fact they may laugh along with you
and i was like oh no
so i've had to shift if you are somebody
who's like
oh there's our little bottle butterball
or look how fat and rolly you are in
your swimsuit to your five-year-old or
four-year-old
that's downloading as fact in your
child's mind and they may look at your
face and mimic you and smile and laugh
along with you i'm just kidding you know
mommy loves you don't do that
don't do that don't do that to your 18
year old don't do that to your 24 year
old
lean into your children to your kids
or to the people that you happen to have
kidnapped and hid in a tower lean into
those relationships um straightforward
not with hmm
just kidding all right here we go
oh okay
so mother as i was saying tomorrow
rapunzel's mother's feeling a little
rundown
would you sing for me
oh of course mother
[Music]
flower blooming glow let your power
shine make the clock reverse bring back
once it's mine through it has been heard
change your face design save what
rapunzel so mother earlier i was saying
tomorrow is pretty big day and you
didn't really respond so i'm just going
to tell you it's my birthday
no no no can't be i distinctly remember
your birthday was last year that's the
funny thing about birthdays they're kind
of an annual thing
mother
i'm turning 18. and i wanted to ask
what i really want for this birthday
actually what i wanted for quite a few
hurdles okay okay rapunzel please stop
with the mumbling you know how i feel
about the mummy blah blah blah blah it's
very annoying i'm just teasing you're
adorable i love you so much oh my gosh
i was gonna say hi you're a human but
she's a cartoon so
i wanna see the floating lights
all right
here's the deal
here's the deal number one did i miss a
pause here
or did i pause too early jimmy
okay all right all right
okay okay a couple things here number
one remember i talked about how
gaslighting is twisting reality she
comes and says hey it's my birthday
tomorrow and she goes ah no it's not and
she's like um it's an annual thing it
happens all the time
nah
right that little bit of you're crazy
you're crazy
and then the mumbling and the insults
like oh you know how i don't like it
don't do that to your kids
right it's this
mommy's exhausted your mere presence is
exhausting me
and our reality is no i'm i'm i'm
bringing joy to this situation i'm
bringing
ah
just you exhaust me what can i
what do you need from me now the person
this this evil human evil cartoon
character has created a world where she
can only get the young girl could only
get what she needs from her and then ah
it's so exhausting that i've got to help
you out you locked her in a tower
there's no food there's no water i don't
i don't have plumbing up there ugh
yeah i got i got to pull your hair to
get up here right you've created a world
that i i have to rely on you
and then you make it a burden
this happens a lot in relationships i
don't want you going out with them i
don't like you hanging out with those
guys cool
um i'm gonna get some other friends that
no no no no
you just need to spend more time with me
okay
all your time with me i just don't feel
comfortable when you go with other
people okay cool
i always just have to do stuff with you
you just wear me out i just can't meet
the needs of right now we're into
gaslighting again all right here we go
[Music]
what
oh well i was hoping you would take me
to see the floating lights
oh
you mean the stars that's the thing
you're crazy
i've charted stars and they're always
constant but i need to stop it right
here
if you are in a relationship where you
are constantly the victim of being of
gaslighting
the links people will go
to not feel crazy
often include oh no those are just stars
no actually i spent the last few years
charting them
right
the links people will go um i would but
you just you're just overweight no
actually i've been in a crossfit gym for
the last four years and i haven't eaten
a carb and since 1987 right
i'm doing this work
people will go to the ends of the earth
to not feel crazy
and a gaslighter will just keep moving
the bar and moving the bar and moving
the bar
okay
they appear every year on my birthday
mother only on my birthday and i can't
help but feel like they're
they're meant for me
i need to see them mother and not just
from my window in person
i have to know what they are
i brought
it's so hard
we cut the scene there it's so hard for
somebody who's being gaslit to actually
say this is what i need
is what i need
and if you go back to the scene
originally this is just so hard for me
to watch because i deal with parents and
their kids so much around this topic
um and relationships
marriages and dating relationships so
much around this
somebody finally gets up the courage to
say hey this is what i need
and a good gaslighter says
you don't need that
and because of the ecosystem that's been
developed the first per thought the
person has is
oh maybe i don't need that maybe i'm
crazy or maybe i'm a bad person or maybe
i'm evil or maybe i'm wrong or maybe i'm
a screw-up or any number of things
i'm going to make hazelnut soup for
dinner your favorite surprise well
mother there's something i want to tell
you oh rapunzel you know i hate leaving
you after a fight especially when i've
done absolutely nothing wrong okay i've
been thinking a lot about what you've
said earlier i hope you're not still
talking about the stars floating lights
and yes i'm leading up to that because i
really thought we dropped the issue
sweetheart all right remember i talked
about beware of the other side of a
compliment
now by the way i need to preface this
we all have to do better at accepting
compliments when somebody comes up and
says hey you're a really great parent
and you are say thank you and move on
don't be like ooh what's coming next
right but be wary of
compliments always be weary of we
language
oh i thought we were done with this
i thought we agreed that we were gonna
have sex every day not just uh twice a
week i thought we
no we agreed on that right
and now suddenly
i'm feeling crazy on behalf of we
like i thought we dropped this says the
evil
kidnapper
uh no this is still a huge deal for me
oh
you're a problem because i thought we
were
no mother i'm just saying you think i'm
not strong enough to handle myself out
there oh darling i know you're not
strong enough to handle
i know
declarative
is the third one i know you're not good
enough
i know you can't handle it
i knew you would screw this up
and a good gaslighter
preys on our deepest fears that we're
not enough
that we can't
and this evil cartoon step
stepmother has gone too far all right
pull yourself out there but if you just
rapunzel we're done talking about this
i know what i'm saying oh come on for
the lights rapunzel you are not leaving
this tower
ever
[Music]
oh
great
now i'm the bad guy
[Music]
parents
how often do we fly off the handle and
then we look at our kids and say
look what you made mommy do
look what you were late and look day you
made dead all angry
it's not true it's gaslighting
it's a lie
when we rage out against our kids when
we snap and yell at them when we act
like children
they don't make us do anything
we are acting like kids
we're acting like whiny bratty kids
and then we blame them for it and our
children spend the rest of our of their
lives trying to figure out
why they keep screwing up and why mom
and dad won't love them
it's time we take ownership of who we
are and how we act
so the greatest
hope that was helpful for those of you
asking about gaslighting that's it right
it's the compliment sandwich and by the
way we teach that in business right if
you have to give somebody some
constructive feedback you know how we do
that because most of us don't have good
enough relationships with the people
that we work with
to say
hey i need you to be on time
right for real be on time
and i've developed a relationship with
james kelly the whole game back here
when they say hey
do it like this please like i know
they're right and so we don't have to
have like a john you're handsome hey i
need to be on time and i love your shoes
john like a compliment because we have a
relationship now we've been in the
trenches for a couple years together now
same with marriages right
if you don't know somebody you have to
come up with a scheme
right so develop those relationships be
weary of the other side of
the
maybe back up
be weary of the other side of a
compliment if somebody's be weary of
just kidding
right
be weary of people who twist your
reality to try to make you feel crazy
gaslighting is abuse
it's dishonesty it's a lie
you're worth more than that